this is gonna be the [__] as long mi see
my baby the best [__] about alright just
making breakfast at all if you've ever
had these before you covered your food
anywhere it's a [__] nightmare I mean
it's food but good food you just don't
know you can trust I don't know how to
[__] turn you so I just carry a load
of these around us in London when you're
training you saw and you need some oats
in your porridge so just pour it in like
that Bob's your uncle can you say that
golden syrup that's my brand water my
vlog for the most part I'm just sitting
on trains going somewhere watching the
YouTube Netflix like mirror is pretty
good it's sort of a different story
every single time allowed got caught one
Gandalf basically they videoed him these
people and they were blackmailing him I
turns out he was a pedo
he's not actually a pedo in the in the
TV shows of Peter he's in another thing
I like call the end of the [__] world
he's sort of like a psychopath who is
thinking about killing his girlfriend
and she's just [__] Raj they end up
sort of becoming perfect for each other
I'd go on a mod adventure it's pretty
easy go through and maybe set one or two
nights of you sitting with your loss or
whatever from now I'll just sort of see
whatever I feel like adding into this
vlog in what goes in goes in it's not a
daily thing it's just whatever I want
this is how we love the support is a
very supportive friend want to recall
just watch the Tottenham career mode I
just started it a dear so this is what I
do
we're at the kickoff HQ and this is sort
of the brain center as we call it yeah
everyone calls it that a lot of
technical stuff use that wouldn't
understand it I'm not even bother
wasting me time explaining it but people
like him they know what's going on
that's the
the sky here but most importantly all of
this can be happening on behind me but
without me putting my youtube log in
there's Lawrence I'm Bryan please
so can we get a [__] for Bryan yeah Oh
Bryan Bryan I'm starting a little bit of
a blog yes I just wanted to show
everyone so that's Steven tries me yeah
and he got mugged by someone who looked
just like you watching no you know he's
a criminal
come to me I wasn't a very sensible
thing there was a good [__] [__]
anyway how's it going everyone
Abbey nails for a couple of days tried
to get an appointment with my GP
probably easier I play monk Everest so
I'm sucked it up I'm going down to the
gym because if I don't go at least once
a week I feel like [__] Bryan's beaten
sort of healthy Bryan in the war on
fitness
[Music]
[Applause]
you got any more time
yes have you seen the podcast have you
seen the podcast can I just say the
funny thing about this is whilst that's
going on down here I look back at
cornichons just going
and as I notice your sauce limit your
vessel it's the best editor new trainee
Skype do you know that he's the best
editor on YouTube he was down the other
end the tailor the competition Lawrence
is Steve for mrs. only one con what
we're going to do when he gets too big
for his boots when he when it becomes
Russian press and you sort of trained
someone of con the missus perfect
perfect I seen the tweet the other day
about your woman is dinner up everyone
let's not talk about that you getting
[__] Iowa she is she's getting shy now
got a guest yeah this is Khan's
girlfriend reduce yourself and and
there's what's his face he's blocking me
walking brian blocking and you know what
I'm gonna get my pair of [__] losers
is that a sub to what I need yeah
did you give you that did you did you
pay for it yeah how could you will you
freebies well [__] man will where's me
[__] you will watch this
I'll Targa me where's me [__] jacket
that's what I wanna know so I were on
the kick off again doing the same to me
guys the problem is problem is when that
becomes a dead body but I fell asleep on
the last podcast so we've got nothing
there at least other than this great
vlog your lucky bastards I'm gonna put
some of the clips in roll the clip I'm
burning me [__] self oh and trying to
do a podcast at the end of the foot and
day we're not being in meetings all
[__] day I was editing videos all the
way down as well
working hard do you want to stop yeah
yeah
your bloody love that one is we've got
Stephen houses on a really aggravating
phone call he's had to clarify that it's
a very stressful important call
look mate he's going back today and I'm
going back tomorrow so I'm gonna ask
what you need to fiddle in your computer
but uh violence won't solve anything but
that doesn't stop Stephen has good
service it's wonderful when you got a
good service isn't that great mate we'll
send someone out to get you thank you
very much
that's great service thank you
watchin fights we're getting [__]
hammer
when you're Brian don't be afraid to
order large because of the coral deal
their bus thank you that money run out
months ago what what station are we up
Victoria we're a Victoria we want to see
Joe Walla talk about the biggest fight
I'm going to be in there cuz you're
Maurice okay sorry for JJ so I prayed
about Jolin but I don't want anyone get
hurt if me and Madonna knockout you too
yeah why not I'd you know because I
don't want anybody to get seriously hurt
but if the two you'll be like I have
felt the lowest I've ever felt in my
life during this experience and
overcoming that that is what that is
where I'm getting my confidence from
that is where because I have proven to
myself on a daily basis what I'm about
and I'm not trying to [__] because I
prove it you are brutally honestly again
the realest guy on YouTube I'd rather be
the realest every [__] day than be
someone who just merchandise son you
know I mean just another day for most
people this would be a big deal for me
Wednesday all of these thoughts yeah
that's the squad you might notice
Lawrence isn't yeah don't tell me what
he's doing I'm just trying to get the
awards do you know what I mean
[__] him I thought I have some of this
and just enjoy meself
it's what I do so I'm up against Akira
you know I've had a long-standing
relationship with her I never thought it
would come to this
yeah spent fantasizing overall now it's
sort of me versus over it sort of seems
like a natural eventual meeting of the
two you know what I mean a lot of
friction over the years between work and
now we will decide a winner
so you just prove the defenders further
forward you can get the tactics right he
never stops we lost we will be inside
the milfs we were beaten by the MILF
right always there bloody lovely I don't
care what you say today look at stats I
don't [__] things so not bitter at
all
who gets the checks in the words of 50
all right you keep the awards I'll get
the checks
so the mums have donors over what we're
going to do now lads are we gonna go and
see naked women double room back are we
gonna go home tell your fiance
Oh
[Music]